hello everybody thanks for coming to the
talk here I know it's late in the day
already what I'm going to talk about
today is Association just wondering how
many of you have heard of association
how many have used it how many like it
and how many don't like it and how many
would like to use it but don't know
enough about it that's that's exactly
the audience that I'm aiming at today so
hopefully I can convince you there's
something useful about it and you'll
start to start to use it so what I'm
going to start to do it's a big project
Association it's the language oriented
project people involved in the
development in teen I don't know if
Constantine's in the audience anywhere
because as he cuts off Tommy come Jones
you might have seen some talks you know
several releases ago of provisional
versions of this it's been completely
rewritten Stephen Wolfram itself has
been a lot involved in the project
particularly in the documentation tally
Stefan has done a fantastic job helping
with the testing many other people
around the company have helped develop
stuff for example brick but champions
group for visualization support so
Stephen really interested in this
association because it's essentially a
symbolic list symbolic representation of
a list and tried to implement something
similar in SMP many years ago but failed
okay and that really got to him and to
be honest the time wasn't really right
because they didn't have the data
structure that I'm going to be talking
about at that time so so let's look at
some significant data structures in
Mathematica packed arrays in version for
sparse arrays in version 5 images graphs
that Charles talked about a little
earlier we also have inversion 10 we
have mesh regions I think Rob and Oliver
talking about that as the compass
association that I'm talking about here
is a language oriented data structure a
little bit different to some of these
other numerical ones that were added and
and something's built on top of
Association data set for example that
term I believe this going to be talk
tomorrow
that so let's just what is an
associative array associative arrays
just a way of storing some pet pairs of
data a key and a value okay and I want
to perform essentially each keys must be
unique I want to perform operations on
this associative array I want to be able
to insert delete look things up and then
with place values if I decide to okay so
here's Association a very simple example
you can think of it as a symbolically
indexed list so instead of using you
know 1 2 3 4 s you would access parts of
the list you can actually use English
names or something a bit more so here's
a list a conventional listing in
Mathematica and here's how to construct
an association so you type Association
and a list of rules of keys and values
and it makes this association object for
you or alternatively you can you can use
this sir this syntax here to input it
directly okay and then once you've done
that and you want to look things up you
can use the symbolic key to get the
value of it or you can use this symbolic
key inside part to get the value of it
okay just like you would use part with
an index of 2 to get the green out of
the list now i can use association with
the English word green to get something
out of the association so you can use it
just like a list of rules but it's more
flexible and more powerful great uses a
similar amount of memory compared to a
list of rules about thirty forty percent
more it uses two or three times less
memory if you start to use those rules
inside replace ok because rules have to
build up certain tables in internally in
mathematica in able to make them to work
fast so as a much much lower memory
footprint it takes about the same amount
of execution time to build an
association as a list of rules but
looking up continually looking up in
association is like looking up in a hash
table it's order one
so essentially it's an association you
can think of it like a dispatch of rules
where dispatch would build views
dispatch many people you suspect we know
a long list of rules they want to
replace something it starts to grow the
complexity of substitution starts to
grow with a number of rules that you
have so you have to make a dispatch
table so no longer any need to do that
if you use association the data
structure itself is optimized for the
substitution so here's a simple data
structure that's not very good for a
task and that's building up a list of
primes if I go through just a do loop
every time I find something that's prime
Q and i append it to a list every time I
pinned to this list I make a new list I
make a new list and I put a new entry in
and so and so this is order N squared
because it's making a copy of a new list
and adding a new entry every time I do
some kind of operation so I need a
better data structure to do that I can
either use a linked list where you use a
list of lists and then flattened at the
end or something like that or i can use
something called a link to ray and the
interface in mathematica to a link to
array is a sow and reap okay they work
with intermediary data structures that
are better at building up something when
I don't know how many operations i'm
going to do but i want to gather
information build up as I go along okay
so just a very quick overview of data
structures trees let's just take some
English words here and organize them
alphabetically okay so I've just say
I've got seven English words and I build
up a tree of those English words and
then I come in and look up given a word
say appendix I come in and look up here
and I see that it's the string
comparison it's less so I go to the left
it's greater than this so I go to the
right and then I do a string comparison
and find its equal okay so this is one
data structure the problem with trees is
that as you add and delete you kind of
unbalanced the tree and so you need to
rebalance it to make the the complexity
good so a second data structure
sometimes school is also a tree
unfortunately or called a try from
retrieval this is similar to a tree but
slightly different it's optimized for
look up so now I split up the English
words I've taken like prefixes as I go
through and look up the word if I go and
look up appendix first I look up the
first part of it then I look up the
second portion and the third portion so
essentially I split up my words into
different pieces and each of these nodes
is no longer the full key it's no longer
the full thing but I'm looking at its
some piece of it and that makes
searching more efficient and
unfortunately that makes the debts of
this tree or the storage of this sir of
this data structure a little bit bigger
so another one that's very nice that we
use a lot internally in Mathematica is a
hash table and the nice thing about this
it's not specific to strings when you
hash you build an integer number that
corresponds to any expression okay that
single integer number is then used to
insert your expression into a table so
let's take these English words again and
let's make a character sure it's jumbled
around these these these characters and
give them numbers and shuffle shuffle
the bits around and make an integer
number and then let's take a hash table
of prime size usually here I've got a
table of size 13 and let's put these
English words into this hash table and
and you can see that when i take the
actual hash values which are 64 bit
values mod some size of the table that
tells me the index that i need to go and
look up that took that particular in
english word okay and the nice thing is
that insertion and deletion into this
into this table is is all the one now
now the problem is with a hash table is
as it grows up and fills up it needs to
be rehashed it needs to be resized okay
so we use a strategy like doubling the
size of the hash table you have to keep
track of the load of the hash table just
as trees you had to balance balance them
and that's not good for a real
system in a real-time system you want
the execution time to be nice and smooth
if you suddenly have to freeze the
system and then go and double some array
and then copy everything over that's
problematic so it's good because it's
all n you need to resolve collisions
sometimes when you make an integer
number from two keys they go to the same
integer number so you use some collision
strategy chaining or linear probing or
something like that it requires that you
have a good random mixing hacks hash
function and as I said it's um it's not
so good for real-time systems so this is
the data structure on which association
is based it's kind of a mix of all the
things that I've just talked about in
particular try or trees and hash tables
it's a hybrid of the two things it's a
relatively young data structure it's
appearing a lot now in functional
languages closure this is by drop
javascript haskell o camel Ruby Scarlett
there's a C++ and a c-sharp
implementation a lot of these are
experimental codes not complete still
buggy or whatever the formal ones are
the ones that are the most complete and
the most used they're also taught in
some graduate classes I found some nice
lecture notes here from penn state
university that talks about this data
structure the nice things about this
it's um it's a very good general purpose
data straight jack of all trades data
structure it might not be as optimal in
every single case but it's close enough
to be good enough for most uses so how
does it work well if we just take a
string and we make a 64-bit number hash
value for this string okay then what we
do is we chop up this hash number into
blocks of bits okay we chop it up into
blocks of piss and then starting with
these blocks of bits we use each single
block as an index into some tree
structure okay so the first block of
bits would be the index into an array at
the first level of the tree and the
second block of bits would be the index
into the second level of the tree
II and the third block of bits and index
into the third level of the tree so it
looks something like this for the
example that have here are my English
words here are the first blocks of the
hash of the hash values of these English
words and here are the second ones and
the data structure looks like this this
is the root node and here I've used lots
of 8 bits so each each node here as an
array of size 8 okay and if I go say a
seven and then four then I get the word
append okay the word so so this is the
first index of this array the red and
then the green is the second level when
there are two entries two or more
entries here so there's a 606 so I need
a second and in the second index to
resolve the uniqueness of those things
okay so this is a way of kind of
combining a tree and a hash table can
anyone see a problem with it it's a bit
bloated okay all these X's are empty
nodes okay so we have a similar kind of
problem to a hash table it's not
completely filled up so the missing link
is to try and come up with a sparse
representation of that node okay and the
way that you do that is to take each
index and and pack those indexes of the
O's arrays as bits into a single integer
okay and that single integer is called a
bitmap and that bitmap then represents
only the positions that are non empty in
that previous array okay each level of
the tree so let me just show that
example again this is what the bitmap
tree would look at would look like okay
so now i have only only the nodes which
actually contain the words and inside
this this contains an array now but the
array only has exactly the number of
elements
that I need to resolve in my data
structure and inside each of these is a
bitmap array if I have index seven then
I shift to see if the seventh bit is
active or not if it is active I know
it's in the tree and I can I can go down
the tree and look up some value in my
data structure so what's what is you
know why go from a hash table to this to
this other data structure that's the big
question so why this these functional
language why are they so interested in
this in this other data structure and
the reason is persistency and data
sharing okay so have a big hash table
with a lot of information in it and I
want to just add one entry to the hash
table but I want to keep a copy of the
old hash table right I have to clone the
entire hash table and just add one entry
and say you've got a million or ten
million or something like that elements
that's a lot of data copying these
databases get bigger etc etc so what I
want is some kind of data structure
where I can freely add to it or subtract
from it but not to destroy too much the
structure that's in you know that's
already there all the information that's
already there i want to make sort of
maintain that copy but just modify
enough that i can also store the new
information so here are my english words
again and what i've done is i've just
added one at the end here okay and i
have a little picture that might have to
just squeeze up a bit here okay so this
is my original data structure containing
my original words here this be all this
part here okay and then i have added
this this word i've added this word here
in here here it is applied oh where did
it go
I'm sorry that's here so tight post
gives me so applied is in here okay and
in order to insert this new nodes what I
have to do is I have to make a new root
node and I have to make a new node node
7 here and then I set pointers in this
to the existing data and to the new data
but this is just sharing what was
already there in the previous data
structure so I've kept my previous data
structure and i've added just a couple
of nodes and a new entry and these just
points now to the existing data okay so
instead of having to copy every single
node in every single entry in this
original data structure I've just added
a little bit here that allows me to
store something new but maintain
something old so the association is a
group of nodes that essentially model
something like a hash table and they
don't you dynamically converts an
unspecified to this array format or spar
suffice to this bitmap format
automatically inside ok so let me just
give you one or two examples yeah say I
want to make an association that makes
this association object and then I want
to look up I want to say inside an
association is the key that corresponds
to the symbol a2 is that present in my
table and i get i get true and i get
through without having to go through a
list of rules I'd have to go through
sequentially each one of these to try
and find out if if this key was present
in this data structure I don't it's like
a hash table it's it's just ultima is
independent of the number of rules that
i have here to find out whether this key
is present or not okay and similarly if
something is not present then I can get
that information very quickly
and likewise I can find information
about whether the actual value the
right-hand side of these rules whether
the something is contained in
association or not there are a lot of
functions in Mathematica that have been
completely rewritten and support
Association just like they support lists
so it's a fundamental data structure
that's been like built-in at the lowest
level so since I'm kind of pushing on
for time here I have a lot of a lot of
examples let me just kind of give you
one that was a motivating problem for
implementing association in the Haskell
language ok this person table was doing
Twitter data analysis it's computing a
communication graph from Twitter data
and scanning it daily to allocate what
you call social capital to nodes you
know be people are behaving well they're
making good constructive comments on
Twitter or they're behaving badly and
making very negative comments so ever
and he gets this graph from 100 million
tweets collecting this information daily
and the graph has about 33 million nodes
and he needs a data structure that's
fast for doing this kind of thing so
here's my little model to do this kind
of thing in them in Mathematica so
essentially I've made like a sparse band
reader bath banded array that gives me
control over the shape and the
communication that goes on in this kind
of community ok so just to make things
simple for this talk I've just taken 10
nodes with with a bandwidth of the
sparse array of above 3 and above and
below the diagonal so there's kind of a
limited communication between groups of
people but this easily hundreds of
thousands or millions of nodes is not a
problem to extend to and then these are
now users on Twitter and it's a directed
graph so user one tweaks user four and
he's tweeted in fairly negative comments
here so it's assigned a value of minus
22 and by number four you know tweets
back in a fairly constructive way so
that's given like a positive comment of
with
weight of like 39 okay so let's see if
we can do any actual analysis on that
earthing I'm going to make a bunch of
community graphs for a week of data okay
and then I'm going to build a bunch of
associations I'm going to get the
adjacency matrix of each of those graphs
and I'm going to make a bunch of
associations that connect the users with
their Twitter total Twitter daily totals
ok so that is the sum of all the tweets
that I sent out the sum of all the
weights of all the tweets that I sent
out and then I'm just going to plot it
so I just feed my idea here I build up
my a list of associations one for each
day and I just give it to list plot and
it looks like this so the peaks are you
know positive positive comments on a
particular day from users and the
troughs down here are someone who
tweeted you know very negatively overall
ok and it could do a similar graph of
tweets received by somebody to see if
somebody's particularly you know being
being being targeted and the point about
the association is well I can use it
just I can just take my list of
associations and I can say well how was
user 9 doing during this one-week period
and here's his kind of tweaked total
yeah so started off a little bit
negative got very constructive around
the third day and then kind of got a bit
bitter and twisted towards the end and
started started maybe friday i don't
know friday saturday sunday he had a bad
weekend starting planner tweeting and in
a fairly negative way and i can just use
position min max all of all of the kinds
of functions that use on lists on
associations and I can find out well the
worst tweet total during the entire week
was on day three and it was by user
number three okay and I could obviously
use an association to map indices two
names to hide you know names in
particular I was actually going to use
names of developers here but I thought
well you know if I said Dan was treating
negatively
de7 he might get offended or something
so I thought well better use actually
just use numbers here and this is you
know a very positive user number nine
made the most positive contribution on
the third day but let's look at the so
here I can just do you know just use
normal functions to analyze my
associations like mean I wrap the
rounded mean and I see like this is the
average over seven day period of the
tweet the tweet total for somebody and I
see like her user six has been you know
pretty naughty during this week he's got
a minus fifty tweet total somebody might
want to send him an email just saying
calm it down a little bit or something
these these two users on the average
have been you know fairly good so we
might want to say well you know you've
been contributing well to the community
or something motivate them in that way
however okay I was going to talk about
this or let me just go to the summary
okay I'll just go straight to subway so
Association didn't have that much time
to give you too many examples or did
explain what it is it's a data structure
essentially that allows you to do
operations on things in a more flexible
and more powerful way than a list it
required a considerable amount of
infrastructure we have a separate
garbage collection it's probably the
most complicated data structure in
Mathematica some of the methods for
sparse arrays or whatever they're more
complicated but as a data structure is
probably the most complicated data
structure we had to make lots of
improvements to existing functionality
hashing itself we had to make rules a
little bit more lightweight in terms of
their memory footprint etc and lots of
ongoing things that we're working on
minor bug fixes new functionality and
improving improving performance of this
data structure so so I hope that's given
you some insights and I hope it
stimulated you a little bit to kind of
you know take a look into Association
and if I'm around you know the whole
if you want to talk to me about you know
function Eliza that's missing or things
you'd like to see or uses that you're
thinking of or whatever